صباح الخير مشاهدينا تغطيهنا مستمره
للازمه التي تدخل يومها الثاني عشر في
السودان على الارض ورغم الهدنه التي تدخل
يومها الثاني استمرت المواجهات بين الجيش
والدعم في مناطق متفرقه من الخرطوم وعموم
البلاد مراسل العربيه افاد بوقوع اشتباكات
متقطعه بين الجيش والدعم السريع في احياء
الخرطوم بحري كما اضاف بتوجه عربات تابعه
للدعم السريع من جنوب ام درمان الى مركز
المدينه على الصعيد الانساني اعلنت وزاره
الخارجيه السعوديه ان سفينه تقل الف
وستمائه وسبعه مدنيا من 56 دوله فروا من
العمق في السودان قد وصلت الى السعوديه
الاربعاء في اكبر عمليه انقاذ من نوعها
تنفذها المملكه العربيه السعوديه حتى الان
اذا ورغم الهدنه اسفرت بعض الخروقات خلال
الاشتباكات بين الجيش السوداني والدعم
السريع عن مزيد من الضحايا في الخرطوم
وبقيه الاقاليم وقالت نقابه اطباء السودان
في بيانها اليومي ان عدد الوفيات بين
المدنيين ارتفع الى 295 حاله وفاه بينما
تم تسجيل 1790 حاله اصابه بين المدنيين
منذ بدايه الاشتباكات وذكرت النقابه ان
هناك العديد من الاصابات والوفيات غير
مشموله لعدم التمكن من الوصول للمستشفيات
لصعوبه التنقل والوضع الامني في البلاد
نذكر فقط بهذه الاخبار العاجله اسفل
الشاشه مشاهدينا ومستمعينا الجيش السوداني
يؤكدوا ان عمر البشير لا يزال محتجزا في
مستشفى عسكري تحت حراسه الشرطه القضائيه
الجيش السوداني كما يؤكد في الخبر العاجل
اسفل الشاشه بان الجيش السوداني بان
البشير وعدد من قيادات حزبه محتجزون في
مستشفى علياء العسكري اذا الجيش السوداني
يؤكد ان عمر البشير لا يزال محتجزا في
مستشفى عاليه العسكري الجيش السوداني ايضا
يقول بانه يرفض اي محاولات لربط ما يجري
في السودان بمزايدات على مواقفنا الوطنيه
اذا الجيش السوداني يؤكد الان بان الرئيس
المعزول عمر البشير بعد الانباء التي تم
تداولها عن خروجه من سجن كوبر وبانه خرج
من السجن قبل ان تبدا هذه الاشتباكات
الحديث ايضا كذلك بانه موجود في احدى
المستشفيات تم نقله الى مستشفى عسكري الان
الجيش السوداني يؤكد ان عمر البشير لا
يزال محتجزا في مستشفى عاليه العسكري وعدد
طبعا من قيادات حزبه
وكذلك اضاف الجيش السوداني بانه يرفض اي
محاولات تربط ما يجري في السجون بزيادات
على مواقفه الوطنيه
كما ذكرنا الجيش اكد ان عمر البشير لا
يزال محتجزا في مستشفى عسكري اذا مشاهدينا
وفي ذات الملف شاهدت قاعده الملك فيصل
البحريه في جده تنفيذه اكبر عمليه اجلاء
حتى الان من السودان وذلك بوصول ثالث موكب
اجلاء قادم من بورتسودان السفينه وصلت تحت
حمايه القوات البحريه السعوديه وعلى متنها
87 شخصا من 58 جنسيه
امامكم في الكاميرا عدد من الممثلين
والسفراء والدبلوماسيين لهؤلاء الرعايه
لاستقبالهم وانهاء كافه اجراءات سفرهم من
قبل الحكومه السعوديه ومن قبل ممثلينهم
بشكل كبير جدا خلال الفتره او خلال ساعه
الى ساعتين سوف يتم منها كافه اجراءات
السفر التابعه لهؤلاء الرعايه سوف تستمر
عمليه انزال كما ذكرنا قبل قليل من ساعه
ونصف الى ساعتين ونصف سوف يتم انهاء
الاجراءات ونزولهم الى قاعده الملك فيصل
البحريه ومن ثم الى مقرات السكن سوف يتم
استقبالهم بالاعلام وبالورود وبالحلوى كما
هو المعتاد لنتحدث عن عمليات اجلاء استمرت
لمده ثلاثه ايام هذه هي السفينه او الموكب
الثالث والسفينه السادسه التي عملت على
نقل الرعايه من بورتسودان وسطه
قوات البحريه السعوديه ووزاره وبالتنسيق
مع وزاره الخارجيه والسفاره السعوديه في
الخرطوم وعدد كبير من قطاعات الحكوميه
التي صخرت كافه جهدها للتعامل مع الرعايه
او التعامل مع ملف الرعايه واستقبالهم
بشكل كبير وبعمليات اجلاء مستمره منذ
ثلاثه ايام وحتى هذه اللحظه من المتوقع
خلال الساعات القادمه ان تكون هنالك رحلات
اجلاء قادمه من بورد سودان الى قاعده
الملك فيصل البحريه سوف نستمر بتغطيه عمل
الملف والعمليات الاجلاء المستمره اللي من
قبل الحكومه السعوديه للرعايه الدول
الشقيقه والدول العربيه والدول الاجنبيه
بالباصات الى بورسودان ومن بعد يعني
مقامات المملكه يعني بارك الله فيهم
واخذنا بالعبارات تقريبا الساعه سبعه
الصباح غادرنا من بورسودان والحين وصلنا
اول المملكه الحمد لله على سلامه الجميع
مده اقامتنا تقريبا سبع سنوات او اكثر شوي
كنا مقيمين بمنطقه بحري كافوري شو
المعاناه والمشاهد اللي انتم عشتوها في
السودان اثناء الاشتباكات يعني هو الرعب
الطياره من فوقك كيف هيك عم تقصف يعني رعب
كان فظيع مذيعه يا محمد معانا
يعني رعب نفسي وجسدي
والله كنا بالسودان بالعاصمه الخرطوم في
الخرطوم نفسها الخرطوم نفسه وكان في يعني
نسمع اصوات تقريبا كذا واخر فتره لما قال
لنا انه خلص بدنا نطلع فكانت الضرب قوي
جدا يعني صراحه كان كل شي منظم ما شاء
الله وكان كذا في جنود وكلهم قاعدين
يعطونا ترتيبات يعني فكان الموضوع جدا سهل
الحمد لله
ايوه اهلي من هنا تواصلوا معاهم قالوهم
قالوا لهم نروح على الميناء البري البحري
وجينا والحمد لله كل شيء كان سهل
قبل ذلك رفقت كاميرا العربيه وصول اول
رحله تجاريه الى ميناء جده الاسلامي مع
التفاصيل
نواكب عمليه وصول اجلام الرعايه من جنسيه
متعدده والذين يصلون الى السعوديه عبر اما
قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه او كذلك قاعده
الملك عبد الله الجويه او ايضا هنا في
ميناء جده الاسلامي ولكن نتحدث اليوم عن
وصول اول رحله التجاريه او عبر ميناء جده
الاسلامي وهي السادسه بالنسبه للسفن التي
وصلت السعوديه طبعا هذه الرحله تحديدا نحن
نتحدث عن
من رعايه
الجنسيه الهنديه والتي قدمت او الذين
قدموا عبر السفينه حربيه
هنديه قدمت من بورتو سود
او الاجلاء العمليات الانسانيه يتم
عمل اعطاهم بعض اللقاحات وكذلك اجراء بعض
الفحوصات الطبيه لا هو بعد ذلك يتوجهون
مباشره الى منصات
الخاصه بنهاء اجراءاتهم وبعد ذلك يتم
نقلهم عبر الحافلات المخصصه الى مقرات
اقامتهم
ومن قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه في جده معنى
مراسل العربيه السلطان السلمي السلطان
صباح الخير مرحبا بك معي في هذه التغطيه
المباشره على شاشه العربيه هل زالت عمليات
الاجلاء مستمره وقائمه باتجاه قاعده الملك
فيصل البحريه في جده ام توقفت
اهلا
مشاهدي قناه العربيه فيما يتعلق بالسفينه
التجاريه
الاكبر منذ بدا عمليات الاجلاء في السودان
انتهت منذ قرابه النصف الساعه وتم انزال
جميع الرعايه وقاموا بانهاء كافه اجراءات
السفر الخاصه بهم لدخول الاراضي السعوديه
وتم نقلهم الى مقرات السكن التي خسرت
الحكومه السعوديه وهي عباره عن اربعه
فنادق فيما يتعلق بعمليات الاسلام كما
اوضحت الحكومه السعوديه في بياناتها
وتصاريحها السابقه بان عمليات الاجلاء
مستمره وان السفر السعوديه في الخرطوم
تقبل اعداد كبيره جدا من طلبات الاجلاء من
مختلف الجنسيات العربيه والاجنبيه بشكل
عام وتقوم بدراستها والتعامل مع معظم هذه
الطلبات ويتم نقل الرعايه واصالهم الى
قاعده الملك عبد الله الى قاعده الفيصل
البحريه عبر ميناء بورد السودان في رحله
بحريه تستمر او تاخذ ما بين ثمانيه الى
عشره ساعات بحرا نتحدث على جهود كبيره
وخدمات كبيره يعمل عليها قوات لتعمل عليها
القوات البحريه السعوديه في عمليات النقل
والتامين هؤلاء الرعايه وصولا الى القاعده
ايضا فيما يتعلق انه من المتوقع بحسن
المصادر من خلال الساعات القادمه ان تصل
السفينه اخرى وهي السفينه السابعه الخاصه
بعمليات الاجلاء من ميناء بورت سودات تتم
عمليه الاجلاء من السودان الى السعوديه
عبر مراحل مختلفه وعديده
وتنسيقات عاليه من قبل الحكومه السعوديه
وكامل الاطراف في السودان لتامين ممرات
بريه بدءا من الخرطوم وصولا الى السودان
في مسافه تصل الى 850 كيلو متر هنالك سفر
السعوديه عملت على تشكيل اللجنه لاستقبال
الطلبات وانهاء كافه الاجراءات المتعلقه
بالرعايه مع حكوماتهم الاجنبيه بعد ذلك
تصل السفر البحريه العسكريه السعوديه الى
ميناء بورتسودان ومثبت تقوم بعمليات النقل
اليوم شاهدنا اكبر عمليه اجلاء منذ بدء
الازمه في السودان عبر سفينه تجاريه مدنيه
تسمى بامانه وهي بطبيعه الحال فعلا قامت
بنقل كافه هؤلاء الرعايه بامانه وبحرص
وكان عمليه التنقل من بورسودان وصولا الى
قاعه الملك عبدا لقاده الملك فيصل البحريه
وسط حمايه مشدده من قبل قوات البحريه
السعوديه حتى رست على مرسى قاعده الملك
فيصل البحريه تم استقبالهم بحضور عدد كبير
من السفراء والدبلوماسيين ممثلي هؤلاء
الرعايه نتحدث على عدد كبير في الجنسيات
وايضا اعداد كبرى من الرعايه شاهدنا اطفال
اوروبا تصل اعمارهم الى ثلاثه اشهر وكذلك
كبار السن وايضا رعايه من دوله احتياجات
الخاصه اكثر شدني بشكل كبير اثناء عمليات
الاجلاء او انزال الركاب من علامات هذه
السفينه هي المواقف والمشاهد الانسانيه
التي يعمل او تعمل عليها القوات السعوديه
من خلال مساعده ومسانده كافه هؤلاء
الرعايه وتقديم كافه الخدمات الخاصه بهم
وتلبيه كافه احتياجاتهم من خلال عمليات
الاعاشه او عمليات الرعايه الطبيه ايضا
اليوم مستشفى الملك فهد العام بجده استقبل
مواطن هندي كان قد وصل عبر طائره هنديه
حطت لحالها في قاعده الملك عبد الله
الجويه بجده مساء يوم امس او عفوا مساء
البارحه تم
[موسيقى]
البحريه وقاعده الملكه عبد الله الجويه
وكذلك من جد الاسلامي نتحدثا من اعلى
نتحدث منه هنالك اكثر من خمسين الجنسيه
بمختلف دول نتحدث الدول على الخليجيه ودول
عربيه ودول اوروبيه ودول امريكا دول
مختلفه تماما اسيويه نتحدث ان يتم التعامل
معهم على مستوى واحد يتم انهاء الاجراءات
في ظرف الساعه الى ساعه ونصف وبعد ان يتم
نقله هنالك تنسيق عالي وكبير جدا بين
الحكومه السعوديه وتحديدا من قبل وزاره
الخارجيه مع السفارات التي تتواجه او
القنصليه التي تتواجد بجده لانها
الاجراءات بشكل سريع ومرن وتذليل كافه
الصعاب او المعوقات التي قد تقرا اثناء
عمليات الاسلام حتى يتسنى لهؤلاء الرعايه
الذهاب او السفر الى بلدانهم عبر المنفذ
الجوي وهو مطار الملك عبد العزيز الدولي
بجده من المتوقع ان يشهد بناء الجده
الاسلامي وقاعده الملك في البحريه وقاعده
الملك عبد الله الجويه عمليات اجلاء خلال
الساعات القادمه وايضا كما بينت حكومه
السعوديه انها تلقي اهتمام كبير جدا في
ملفات اللجنه وتستقبل طلبات كبيره من
حكومات اجنبيه ايضا تحدث انه لا تزال
قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه او القوات
البحريه السعوديه هي مستعده لتنفيذ عمليات
الاجلاء الفائده لتوجيهات خادم الحرمين
الشريفين وكذلك العهد السعودي شكرا جزيلا
لك من قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه في جده
مراسل العربيه سلطان السلمي على كل هذه
المعلومات
ومع دخول عمليات الاجلاء من السودان يومها
السادس واكبت كاميرا العربيه العمليات في
عده دول حيث يشهد مطار بورد سودان الدولي
شرقي البلاد رحلات اجلاء بواقع ثلاث رحلات
جويه يوميا وعلى متنها مئات الرعايه من
الدول الاجنبيه والبعثات الدبلوماسيه
والموظفين الامميين وبينما تتوالى الدفعات
وصلت احدى طائرات الاجلاء الى بيروت
بمساعده السعوديه محمله ب 32 شخصا بينهم
12 فلسطينيا يحملون اوراق اللبنانيه كما
تمر عمليه الاجلاء الى ليبيا عبر ثلاث
مراحل بريه وجويه وبحريه تبدا بالانتقال
الى الحافلات الى ثم الترحيل الى ميناء
جده وصولا الى المحطه الاخيره والسفر
بالطائره الى طرابلس استقبل مطار معيتيجا
الدولي 105 من افراد الجاريه الليبيه في
السودان بعد اجلائهم بسبب الاشتباكات
الدائره هناك
هذا وقال مسؤول في البحريه الامريكيه
لشبكه سي ان ان الولايات المتحده سترسل
سفينه حربيه ثالثه الى السودان تمتاز
بسرعه عاليه نسبيا وذلك بعد يوم واحد من
اعلان وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه ان وصول
سفينه لسواحل السودانيه وتوجه اخرى من بحر
العرب الى هناك اضاف المسؤول البحري ان
السفن الثلاث قادره على نقل مئات الاطنان
من المعدات او عدد كبير من الافراد بسرعه
عاليه نسبيا
تركوا الحرب وراءهم بحثا عن طريق للخروج
من السودان الاف الاشخاص من عشرات
الجنسيات غادروا للوصول الى بر الامان
وعبر وجهات مختلفه كثيرون وجدوا ما تسنى
لهم من وسائل مغادره السودان بحرا او جوا
في حين لجا اخرون للطريق الاصعب بقطع
الجغرافيا السودانيه برا للدول المجاوره
مفوضيه شؤون اللاجئين في تشاد اعلنت ان
عشرين الف لاجئ وصلوا الى هذا البلد مع
توقعات بان يتبعهم مئه الف اخرون في اسوا
الحالات اما في جنوب السودان فترجح
التقديرات الامميه نزوح ما يصل الى 170
الف شخص ثلاثه ارباعهم من لاجئي جنوب
السودان الذين سيعودون في رحله نزوح جديده
لكن في بلدهم هذه المره حتى من وجدوا
دولهم او دوله ثالثه تمد لهم يد العون فهم
يعانون الامرين لمغادره السودان في رحله
محفوفه بالمشاق تليها نقاط توقف مؤقته لمن
غادروا برا الى مصر او جوا الى جيبوتي او
بحرا عبر بورسودان وصولا الى السعوديه
العربيه
اعلنت هيئه المرافق او الموانع البريه في
مصر تجاوز القادمين من السودان الذين
تمكنوا من دخول البلاد عبر معبره قسطل
وارجين 10.000 شخص وقالت في بعين الله ان
القادمين من السودان من مختلف الجنسيات
ويتم التعامل مع العاملين بشكل مكثف من
اداره الجوازات والجمارك وغيرها من الجهات
لاستيعاب الكثافه المتوقعه
ينظم الينا هنا في الاستوديو القائم
باعمال سفاره السودان لدى السعوديه مهند
عمر عباسي مهند مرحبا بك معي في هذه
التغطيه الخاصه للعربيه بدايه اسالك كيف
تنظر السودان للدوره المملكه العربيه
السعوديه اليوم في الاسماء السودانيه
بشقها الانساني
شكرا جزيلا في البدء دعني اخي نايف اترحم
في بدا على ارواح
الارواح السودانيه التي فقدت جراء هذه
الازمه الاخيره
المجد والخلود لشهدائنا في السودان شهداء
القوات المسلحه شهدائنا من المواطنين
السودانيين ونتمنى ايضا عاجل الشفاء
للجرحى والمصابين
قبل ان ندلف الى الى الدور المملكه
العربيه السعوديه الشقيقه
اسمح لي في البدء ان اتحدث عن هذه الاحداث
ربما يتساءلك كثيرون عن
ماذا حدث او ماذا يحدث في السودان حقيقه
هذه الاحداث التي بدات في السودان في
الخامس عشر من شهر ابريل الشهر الجاري
كانت احداث مفاجئه جدا الم يتوقعها اي احد
سبب عدم التوقع انهاء في نفس اليوم الذي
حدث في هذه الاحداث المؤسفه كان هناك
اجتماع سيتم بين رئيس فخامه السيده فخامه
الفريق اول ركن عبد الفتاح برهان رئيس
مجلس السياده الانتقائي الانتقالي والقائد
العام للجيش السوداني
رئيس قوات
الدعم السريع هذا الاجتماع كان
يختص بمناقشه موضوع دمج قوات الدعم السريع
في القوات السودانيه ولكن طبعا وفق شروط
خاصه سبحان الله يعني فجاه انقلبت الامر
الى محاوله التمرد محاوله قلب النظام
السلطه ونتج عنه الاحداث التي تابعت
جميعكم في
نعم نتج عنها هذه الاحداث وبالطبع وجود
مشكله كبيره بالنسبه
حدثت مشكله في المعابر
توقف مطار الخرطوم الدولي لانه كان من اهم
الاهداف الاستراتيجيه للقوات المتمرده او
القوات المتفلته ضرب المصالح ضرب الاماكن
المهمه في السودان القصر الجمهوري مطار
الخرطوم الدولي المنشات الحيويه مؤسسه
الكهرباء المياه فمن ضمن هذه
الاماكن التي تم ضربها مطار الخرطوم
الدولي
اليوم الاول تسببت هذه الاحداث كلها في
وجود مجموعه كبيره من
العالقين ان رجعنا الى موضوع السؤال
العالقين في السودان الذين كانوا من جهات
من بعض
السفارات والمنظمات
والحمد لله بحمد الله تعالى
في هذا الصدد ايضا اتقدم بالشكر الى وزاره
الخارجيه السودانيه الى معالي السيده
الوزير معالي السيده الوكيل وكل الاخوه
الزملاء العاملين في وزاره الخارجيه
السودانيه لجهودهم الحسيسه والكبير
والمقدره قامت الخارجيه السودانيه بتلقي
العديد من البلاغات من البعثات
الدبلوماسيه والهيئات والمنظمات
بحدوث اعتداءات على مقرها قامت وزاره
الخارجيه بالتواصل مع جهات السودانيه
القصه لتامين هذه المقر
ساهمت الوزاره الخارجيه السودانيه في
تامين ايضا خروج اعضاء البسات الدبلوماسيه
والمنسوبين لها الذين يعملون في جهات اخرى
والحمد لله تعالى يعني تم تم تامين خروج
امن لهم عبر المعابر البريه والجويه كم
عدد الدول تقريبا التي ابلغت وزاره
الخارجيه بانها تعرضت مقرها الى
اقتحامات او محاوله السيطره عليها العديد
من من السفارات ابلغت هناك اعتداء على
داخل المقر هناك اعتداء على الكاميرات
المراقبه خارج هناك تداعى على الموظفين
ارتداء على السيارات ضرب نار وفي هذه
المناسبه نترحم على روح الله
الموظف السفاره المصريه في الخرطوم الذي
راح العسكري هو نائب الملحق الاداري
الملحق الاداري نعم هو موظفي السفاره وهو
يعني
نتاسف يعني يعني تعازين الحاره لاسرته
الكريمه في جمهوريه مصر العربيه الشقيقه
نحن نتاسف لهذا هذه الاحداث
سيد عمر ماذا عن وضع مهند عفوا وضع
السودانيين العالقين في المملكه الان كيف
يمكن الحديث عنها كيف تم التعامل معهم من
التواصل معكم اولا التعامل ايضا مع
الحكومه السعوديه سواء من كانوا عالقين
موجودين في السعوديه او من كانوا اهمينا
بالذهاب الى السودان نعم ايضا هنا
يجب ان نتقدم بالشكر
للمملكه العربيه السعوديه
ممثله في جلاله الملك سلمان ابن عبد
العزيز خالد الشريفين
و العهد حقيقه المملكه العربيه السعوديه
يعني قامت بدور كبير جدا سواء كان بالنسبه
للعالقين سواء كان بالنسبه للهدنه الان
موجوده في السودان وهذه الهدنه بالمناسبه
هي التي ساهمت في خروجها
في موضوع الادلاع دوره المملكه العربيه
السعوديه بالنسبه للسودانيه العالقين في
المملكه العربيه السعوديه
في البدء نريد ان نوضح العالقين الموجودين
في المملكه العربيه السعوديه قدموا الى
المملكه العربيه السعوديه لاداء الشعائر
شعيره العمره وزيره المدينه المنوره وهذه
الاحداث تزامنت في الايام الاخيره من شهر
رمضان المعظم وهذه الايام الايام المباركه
من اكثر الايام التي يعني يرغب السودانيين
دائما في تواجدهم في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه في هذه الايام المباركه صادفت
هذه الايام حدوث هذه الاحداث المؤسفه
والتي ناسف ان تحدث في هذا الشهر الكريم
مجموعه كبيره من العالقين وجدوا انفسهم في
يعني في وضع لا يمكنهم من العوده الى
السودان سواء عبر الطريق البحري او سواء
طريقه طائرات لاغلاق مطار الخرطوم الدولي
المملكه العربيه السعوديه نشكر لها جهودها
في توفير السكن والايواء وتقديم الخدمات
الطبيه ايضا لاعاده كبير جدا من المواطنين
السودانيين
وقامت اللجنه العربيه السعوديه بتشكيل
لجنه الان في تواصل كبير جدا معهم من دون
ذكرى اسماء يعني
وهذه اللجنه تواصلت معنا في السفاره
السودانيه بالرياض ولكن تواصلها الكبير
ايضا كان عبر القنصليه السودانيه العامه
بجده
باعتبار انه العالقين يعني مجموعه كبيره
جدا منهم موجودين الان في جده اعتبروا عن
ميناء البري وايضا اذا سمح لي الوقت في
هذا اللجنه تعنى بشؤون العالقين السوداني
نعم نعم هذه اللجنه كما تشكيلها خصيصا
وتواصلت معنا منذ بدا الاحداث
وتكفلت بايواء وسكن العديد من الاسره
السودانيه وايضا
يعني بعض الظروف الصحيه حصلت طبعا وايضا
تكفلت بها وهذا الامر يعني انا لا اريد ان
اتحدث عنه لانه ليس بغريب عن المملكه
العربيه السعوديه هي دورها دائما رائد في
مساله الاحداث اسمع لي في دقيقه واحده ان
اتقدم ايضا بالشكر
القنصليه العامه السودانيه بجده وعلى
راسها الوزير المفوض القنصل العام محمد
حسن بعشوم والذي كان له واركان حربه او
الاسلاف الموجوده في السفاره لدورهم
الكبير ايضا في رعايه المواطنين
السودانيين واذكر ايضا
انهم يعني لا يوجد اي مواطن سوداني اتواصل
مع القنصليه العامه بجده او السفاره
السودانيه في الرياض الا ووجد كله عون منا
هل بداتم ترتيبات الاجلال السودانيين
الموجودين في السعوديه باتجاه بورت سودان
نعم بدانا بتنسيق مع سلطات السعوديه
المختصه هذه الاجراءات من ناحيه التسجيل
من ناحيه الترتيب والتنسيق والان يعني
بدات بدات اعداد الحمل في التحرك لانه هذه
كما ذكرت الهدنه المعلن الان سمحت بوجود
حركه بحريه
من بورسودان الى جده وبالعكس فبدات بعض
الاعداد
المواطنين السودانيين في التحرك والعوده
مره اخرى الى السودان عبر ميناء جده هل
هناك اعداد مقدره لاعداد السودانيين الذين
علقوا في السعوديه مع نشوب هذه الازمه
اذا جئنا للعداد تقريبا تقديريه تقديريه
يعني اعداد كبيره جدا يعني
بالالاف لانه انا ذكرت في مقدمه حديثي انه
هذه الفتره الذي حدثت فيها الاعداد هي
فكره يعني عشره اواخر من رمضان يعني هذه
ايام يعني معظم المواطنين السودانيين يحب
اعضاء هذه الايام في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه فبالتالي وضع طبيعي انه تكون
اعداد كبيره جدا بالالاف يعني انا لا احب
ان اذكر عدد معين لكن اعداد كبيره صراحه
هل هناك من السفارات تواصلت معك شخصيا هنا
في السعوديه لترتيبات الاجلاء او للسؤال
ايضا عن يعني كيفيه خروج مواطنيهم او
بعثاتهم الدبلوماسيه الموجوده في الخرطوم
نعم حقيقه تواصلت معنا مجموعات كبيره من
الساده السفراء او الدبلوماسيين بالسفاره
الموجوده بالمملكه العربيه السعوديه حصرا
بالرياض لو ان نحن مختصين الرياض او
المنطقه الشرقيه
تواصلوا معه معنا والحمد لله قمنا بتوفير
التاشيرات الدخول لهم
يعني نحن عملنا ايام هذه الاحداث 24 ساعه
في اليوم وكنا عندنا غرفه مناوبه او غرفه
طوارئ وكنا يعني هناك زملاء وايضا يعني في
هذه السانحه لعشيد باعضاء السفاره
السودانيه بالرياض فردا فردا من دون ذكر
اسماء لانه يعني كانوا يقعدون الليل في
السفاره هل تعلم ان هناك من كان يبيت يترك
اطفاله اسرته في السفاره الخدمه للمواطن
السوداني تواصلوا معنا العديد من السفارات
وقمنا بمنحهم تاشيرات دخول في نفس اللحظه
او في نفس اليوم يعني
فتحنا ابوابنا مشرعه كالعاده سفاره
سودانيه
هذه السفارات اعطيناها هذه التاشيرات
وطلبنا منهم ايضا
يعني كل من يريد تاشيره دخول الى السودان
غرض الاجلاء نحن 24 ساعه جاهزون لهم طيب
اشكرك جزيل الشكر على وجودك معي هنا
باعمال السفاره السودانيه لدى السعوديه
مهند عمر عباس شكرا جزيلا شكرا لك شكرا
جزيلا شكرا شكرا
اذا واتهم سودانيون سائقي الحافلات بزياده
اسعار التذاكر السفر من الخرطوم الى
ولايات اكثر امانا الامر الذي اثار غضب
واستياء الاهالي واعتبر الكثير من
السودانيين الامر استغلالا واضحا من قبل
السائقين لكسب المال رغم الظروف الصعبه
التي تمر بها البلاد بسبب المعارك
المندلعه في مدنها بين قوات الجيش
السوداني والدعم السريع
استغلال ذاته بشر من اصحاب الاوساط
ويعني التذكره الصباح بسعر والمسبي سعر
وبعد باكر بيسعد عن الصباح الليله
ب 350 اسوان
القاهره ب 400 الف
مراسله العربيه كانت رصدت الاجواء في
منطقه المعموره جنوب الخرطوم حيث يحاول
المواطنون وبعض الاجانب مغادره العاصمه
هربا من المعارك
والله
[موسيقى]
يعني حتى المواد التموينيه في الدكاكين في
العيش بقى في اي حاجه حتى الاندومي
من بيتنا الثاني دخل على شقتي الرصاصي
سكينه الدعامه بنص الحله الرصاص تحت كرعنا
يعني
مسافرين الاسره كلها
النزول حاليا هذه البساط السفريه تتجه
لمناطق مختلفه من
السودان يعني من الولايات وهذا البث
تحديدا يتجه الى القاهره ومعي هذا الشاب
مرحبا وعليكم السلام ورحمه الله
مسافرين من الخرطوم فالاوضاع يعني معلومه
يعني تعلمونها جيدا كيف الاوضاع في
السودان
عدم توفر مراكز تجاريه عدم توفر خبز يعني
حتى اذا
فتحت
منتظرين في واحد بتاع دكان منتظرينه من
الصباح يمكن اكثر من خمس ساعات حتى يفتح
وحتى نسبه الوضع الخطا حتى لو في تفتح نص
ساعه ساعه وبتغلق
فصعوبه يعني حتى في توفير لقمه العيش في
استغلال تام من
اصحاب الباصات في اصحاب الباصات التذكره
بعشرين لحد اسوان حاليا التذكره ب 300
يعني
بمثابه 300% او اكثر
ومن بورت سودان ينضم الينا الصحفي عبد
القادر باكاش عبد القادر مرحبا بك معي في
هذه التغطيه العربيه اولا كيف تتم عمليه
الاجلاء من بورت سودان حتى هذه اللحظه ما
الذي يمكن رصده
اداب كبيره من الرعايه العرب
والجاليات الاسلاميه وكل الاتحاد
الاوروبيه والاجنبيه
بتنسيق مشترك بين القوات المسلحه
السودانيه والسلطات السعوديه الان السيد
السفير يشرح بنفسه
وعدد من مساعديه وسلطات سعوديه
اعداد متكامل الان تجري
التشغيل كافه الاجراءات لكل الرعايه حتى
الذين لديهم اشكالات في الوثائق تمت
معالجتها وتم اجلائهم بحمد الله هناك لجان
ولايه مشكله لاحد الغرض تتابع هذا الامر
كيف يتم المدينه بها عادات كبيره من
الواطنين
المدينه مدينه مدينه بورسودان وصلتها
عادات كبيره جدا من الوافدين السودانيين
الذين وفدوا من العاصمه بعد هم لديهم
احالهم في مدينه بورسودان وبعدهم جاؤوا
للبحث عن خروج عامل من العاصمه الى مناطق
اكثر عمنا وبعدهم
يعملون الى جمهوريه مصر العربيه
وحملت الجنسيات المزدوجه ايضا لديهم اتجاه
على الخروج الى بلدانهم التي يحملون
الجوازاتها هل هناك سودانيون يهمون
بالخروج من بورتودان باتجاه مصر مباشره او
باتجاه المملكه
بعض السودانيين المختبرين الذين لديهم
امكانات ماديه تمكنهم من الحركه الان
يعملون في الخروج من السودان الى مصر
باعتبارها من البلدان الامنه وهناك بعض
السودانيين قادروا الجنسيات المزدوجه
غادروا ظهرا الى جده ومنها سيسافرون الى
بلدانهم منهم وزير الخارجيه السابق السيد
ومريم غادر في باخره الامس فاخره نما الى
مدينه جده ومنه ان شاء الله سيكون الى
سيسافر الى امريكا حسب ما علمتها هل هناك
تقديرات لعدد السفن التجاريه المتوقفه
الموجوده في بورتسودان والتي يعني تنتظر
ان تجلي عدد من
البعثات الدبلوماسيه او الوافدين
الموجودين ايضا كذلك في السودان
تتبع لعدد من الدول وصلت باريجات عسكريه
هنديه وصلت بارجه فرنسيه من امس وهناك
اتجاه على استخدام بارج امريكيه لاجراء
بعض الرعايه
وهناك مجهودات مغدره تتم من جانب السلطات
السعوديه الى كل
على نفقه المملكه يتم ترحيله وتسعين
اجراءاتهم واستضافتهم
والان في نادي هيئه الموارد البحريه تم
تشكيل الغرفه
لتصنيف الناس وتجهيزهم وتكمله اجراءاتهم
بالتنسيق مع السلطات السودانيه ايضا ماذا
عن الكثافه البشريه في ميناء بورتسودان
حتى الان عبد القادر كيف يمكن وصفها
والله ابدا القادمين العدد كبير جدا
والمدينه طبعا
لم تعتاد من قبل على قدوم هذه الاعداد
القصيره من المواطنين ومن الرعايه
والموظفين لمنظمات الامم المتحده
موظفين تم اجلائهم وبعد
الان عددهم في مدينه بورسودان مغارنه
بالايام السابقه الان العدد قليل نسبيا ثم
الى اغلب الناس
الان عمليات حتى الان ومستمره وكل يوم ترد
مجموعات جديده طبعا التفويج يتم من العجله
الخرطوم الى مدينه بورسودان عبر القوات
المسلحه السودانيه وبالتنسيق مع
السفارات يتم تفويجهم من العاصمه الى
الميناء في تاريخ شاغر جدا وطويل ورحله
سفر لكن الفريق امن حتى الان لم تظهر اي
تقلبات من اي جانب
نظرا لاعمال المنطقه نهر النيل وولايه
البحر الاحمر يعني هناك التزام تام بوقف
اطلاق النار في هذه المناطق المؤديه الى
ميناء بورتسودان
الان في التزام على الطريق على الاقل في
التزام من الجانبين على عدم اطلاق النار
جميع
التفويج التامه خلال المرات السابقه لم
يحصل على الطريق اي اعتداء من
الموظفين العمومين الحمد لله
تعيش حتى الان في وجه معيش ممتاز اغلب
الغادمين الحمد لله لم يعانوا من اشكالات
في المواد الغذائيه والاستهلاكيه والنزله
الهوائيه فنادق المدينه والشكر والفندقيه
الان تقريبا جميعها ممتلئه
لم ارشد يعني الناس الان لم يجدوا معه
اغلب الناس تم ايواءهم في الفنادق
والمنازل واغلب السودانيين الذين غادموا
ايضا
يعني نزلوا مع ذويهم في مدينه بورسلان
ومعارفهم كيف تتم مساله التعامل مع من
لديهم اشكاليات في الاوراق الثبوتيه او
حتى في اوراق السفر كذلك السيد عبد القادر
حكومه المملكه مجتهده في تفصيل الجراء
الامكان
والتساهل في الاجراءات
الوثائق الا من يعني من يشقون في هويته
لكن الذين تم التعرف على هويته والاطمئنان
على وضعهم تمت معالجه اوض يعني رسمنا بعض
يعني منشوفين بعد الدول كانت
وصاحبهم ليست كافيه او غير مكتمله تم
استثنائهم للصعود للبوافر واجنائهم
الان الجنسيات العربيه جميعها تعمل بشكل
منتظم وجميع الذين التقيناهم كانوا يشكرون
في حكومه المملكه العربيه وسعاده السفير
على اهتمامه وتسهيل اجراءاتهم ويعني
التعامل معهم بربيع عالي جدا الحمد لله
اشكرك جزيلا شكرا
لكم يعني معهم اطفال ونساء لذلك يتم يعني
التعامل معهم تعامل الانساني من جانب
المملكه اشكرك جزيل الشكر من بورسودان
الصحفي عبد القادر بكاش على كل هذه
المعلومات والتفاصيل ومنه الى زميل هاني
الصفيان الذي ينضم الينا من ميناء جده
الاسلامي هاني اصفيان مرحبا بك معي في هذه
الساعه يعني الصوره نقلها لنا زميل عبد
القادر قبل قليل من من بورت سودان ماذا
عنك انت ايضا في جدهاني ماذا لديك
نعم اهلا بك نايف واهلا بمشاهدي قناه
العربيه طبعا العربيه ما زالت تواكب عمليه
وصول اجلاء رعايه من جنسيات مختلفه
ووصولهم تحديدا الى السعوديه وتحديدا ايضا
الى مدينه جده الواقعه غرب السعوديه وهي
احد اهم الموانئ في العالم اليوم عده دول
عده دول تستعين بهذا الميناء سواء من خلال
سفنها او فرقاطاتها واحده من هذه
الفرقاطات التي تستعين بها الان الفرقاطه
لورين الفرنسيه وهي فرقاطه حربيه كما
تشاهدونها تصل لهذه اللحظات وهي تحمل
قرابه ال 400 شخص من رعايا من جنسيه
متعدده اوروبيه وكذلك امريكيه وايضا من
استراليا هذه الصور الاولى التي ترصدها
العربيه للفرقه الفرنسيه لورين والتي تصل
الى ميناء جده الاسلامي والتي
سمحت لها السلطات السعوديه وكذلك قام او
قامت رقم ميناء جده الاسلامي بالسماح لها
ايضا بوقوفها على هذا الرصيف عموما سوف
ينضم معي السيد الطيب ادم وهو ممثل الامم
المتحده للطفوله والذي سوف يكون المشرف
على وصولها الرعايه مرحبا بك استاذ الطيب
لو نتحدث اليوم عن وصول السفينه لورين وهي
او الفرقاطه لورين الحربيه الفرنسيه دعنا
نتحدث كم تحمل على متنها ما هي الجنسيات
وايضا كيف كان عمليه وصولها الى ميناء جده
وتعاون السلطات السعوديه والسماح لها
بالوقوف والدخول الى مياهها الاقليميه
شكرا جزيلا في البدايه اتقدم بالشكر
الكبير الشكر الجزيل
لخادم الحرمين الشريفين الملك سلمان بن
عبد العزيز ال سعود
ولي عهد الامين صاحب الصهي الملكي الامير
محمد بن سلمان بن عبد العزيز على الدعم
الكبير الذي قدمته المملكه العربيه
السعوديه
موظفي الامم المتحده
لجده من بورسودا الى جده وكما ذكرت هنالك
حوالي 400 موظف من اللون المتحده وسريم هم
الان وصلوا الى جده وفي طريقه ان شاء الله
الوصول الى جده ومن ثم ذلك ينتجون الى
الدول الاخرى الى كينيا والى ايضا يوغندا
نحن وجدنا كل التعاون وكل التسهيلات في
جده هنا من
الموانع البحريه وكذلك سلطات المختلفه من
الجهات الامنيه كل الموظفين هنا يعني
قدموا كلنا كل الدعم وكل تسهيلات وكذلك
المملكه العربيه السعوديه هنالك انتهاء
تواصل مع وزاره الخارجيه ايضا منذ يومين
وهم الان يعني يقدرون ايضا كل التسهيلات
لوصول هؤلاء
الموظفين المتحده
وكل الاجراءات حتى ايضا في هناك بعض
الموظفين جزء منهم يعني مرضى او يعانون
ببعض الامراض هنا الان موجود سياره
الاسعاف موجوده في طاقه طبي موجود للاشراب
عليهم
يعني نحن نشكر المملكه العربيه السعوديه
وهذا طبعا يعني دين دين المملكه العربيه
السعوديه في دائمه تقديم الدعم وفي كذلك
دورها الانساني الكبير هي رائده للعمل
الانساني
وكذلك طبعا بالاضافه لهذه الاجلاء المملكه
العربيه السعوديه دائما تقدم دعم لكل
الدول التي تمر به ظروف انسانيه من خلال
مركز الملك سلمان
للاعمال الانسانيه والاغاثه نسمي هذه
الدعم للاولى المتحده بشكل عام تعودنا
دائما من الامم المتحده هي لمن تقوم
بمساعده والجلاء في مناطق المنكوبه اليوم
الامم المتحده تستعين بالدول من هذه الدول
هي
كيف هي تتم الاليه وايضا هل هناك سفن اخرى
غير الفرقاطه لورين سوف تكون ايضا من ضمن
هذه الفرقات التي سوف تقف على رصيف ميناء
جده الاسلامي نعم نعم بالتاكيد هنالك ايضا
سفن ستتولى لانه هنالك اعداد كبيره الان
من الموظفين المتحده
حوالي 1200 موظف الان
4 بالاضافه الى موجودين يعني تم ايلاف في
الوقت الحالي حوالي 1400 موظف
وجزوا منهم وصلوا اليوم حوالين 400 موظف
الان ولكن ما زال هنالك ايضا حوالي 600
موظف موجودين في بورسودان وسيتم ايضا
اجلائهم الى بورسودان الى جده في الايام
القليله القادمه يعني
بعد يوم القادم في هذه الايام القادمه
بينما ساعود اليك يا سيد طيب ولكن دعنا
ايضا نتعرف على هذه السفينه وهذه الفرقاطه
الحربيه عزيزي نايفه ومشاهدي قناه العربيه
والتي ايضا هي سبق وان وصلت في السعوديه
ولكن كانت في مهام تمارين عسكريه مشتركه
مع السعوديه ولكن اليوم هي تقف على هذه
هذا الرصيف وتحديدا في ميناء جده الاسلامي
ولعلها لاول مره تقف على ميناء تجاري
وايضا خاص بالاعمال التجاريه والمدنيه
ولكن تقف في مهمه هي مهمه انسانيه استعنت
سمحت لها السلطات السعوديه بان تقف على
هذه الرصيف من اجل اجلاء كما تحدث السيد
الطيب ادم وهو ممثل الامم المتحده للطفوله
والذي تحدث ان هناك الان تحمل قرابه 400
من جنسيه مختلفه وايضا من هؤلاء الاشخاص
هم من يحتاجون الى ايضا رعايه خاصه بعضهم
لديهم اصابات ولكن دعنا بمن نتحدث لديهم
اصابات او معوقات طبيه او صحيه بالاصح هل
هي بسبب الازمه الدائره الان بين طرفي
نزاع في داخل السودان ام اصابات اخرى لا
ليس هم ليس لديهم اصابات يعني هذه امراض
صحيه عاديه يعني بعض الكبار السن وكذلك
جزء من النساء في حواليه سته اشخاص
يحتاجون فقط لرعايه الطبيه اننا نتحدث
اليوم يعني هناك ايضا كوادر صحيه اكيد
السعوديه قامت بتنسيق مع وزاره الصحه
السعوديه من اجل او قمتم بتنسيق مع وزاره
الصحه السعوديه لتواجد مركبات الاسعاف نعم
نعم حقيقه
وزاره الصحه وكذلك المسؤولين هنا في جده
تنسيق كامل مع جهات الصحيه لافاد
طاقم طبي وكذلك
سيارات اسعافه الان في
موجود وهناك موجوده وهم الان ينتظرون فقط
وصول او خروج نقول
الاشخاص الذين هم يعني يعانون بعض
الوضع الصحي
للقيام بتقديم الرعايه الطبيه فهذا ايضا
عمل انساني كبير جدا نثمنه ونقدره للمملكه
العربيه السعوديه ماذا عن حال والوضع
الحالي الامن بالنسبه للاخرين ان تتعددت
هناك قرابه الالف شخص ما زالوا يقطنون
هناك يمكتون في بورتو السودان ما هو حالهم
كيف وضعهم والجميعهم في بورتو السودان ام
ايضا ما زالوا في مناطق علقه داخل السودان
لا هما جميعنا الان في بورسودان هم يعني
تم اجلؤه من الخرطوم قبل يومين ووصلوا
بورسود موجودين هنالك اوضاعوا حسب ما اعرف
اعضائهم
في في حاله جيده ليس هنالك اشكالات ولكن
طبعا كما تعلم ان الظروف الموجوده الان
يعني خلفت بعض الاشكالات
وكذلك بعض الجوانب النفسيه التي يكونوا
مروا عليها خلال رحلتهم من الخرطوم الى
بورسودان التي امتدت لغرابه اليومين في
هنالك يعني لك مره اخرى السيد الطيب ولكن
ايضا نستعرض مع الصور التي نلتقطها الان
وتلتقطها كاميرا العربيه ها هي تتحرك ايضا
احدى الاليات الخاصه برفع الجسر الذي سوف
يكون الرابط بين الفرقاته وبين ايضا رصيف
السفينه ليتمكن ايضا الاشخاص او التي
اقلتهم السفينه من النزول من هذا الجسر
اليوم نحن نتحدث ايضا عن عمليه اجراء ليس
فقط على هذه الفرقات نايف ولكن هناك ايضا
القوات بالنسبه للقوات البحريه السعوديه
قامت باجلاء العديد من الرعايه او جنسيات
متعدده كان اكبرها واضخمها هي اكبر عمليه
اجراء تمت صباح هذا اليوم بعدد وصل الى
اكثر من
1670 شخص من 40 جنسيه وايضا هنا الفرقاطه
سمحت لها السلط السعوديه من خلال عملياتها
الانسانيه التي دائما ما تقوم بها
السعوديه
بوصول هذه الفرقاطه الى الرصيف من جده
الاسلامي كي يتم اجلاء رعايه من الامم
المتحده سعود ايضا للسيد الطيب ادم مره
اخرى طيب
هل وصلتكم اي طلبات من دول اخرى سواء
اقليميه على مستوى الشرق او دول منطقه او
كذلك اوروبيه باجلاء رعاياها سواء
دبلوماسيين او كذلك يعملون داخل السودان
هنالك تنسيق مع الجهات المختلفه مع الدول
المختلفه لاجراء رعايه هنا الذين يعملون
في الامم المتحده هذا التنسيق الذي يتم
فهنا فالان نحن في هذا المكان نجد انه
هنالك اكثر من خمس او ست او سبعه
موظفين لسفارات مختلفه الان هم حضروا الى
هذا المكان لاستقبال رعاياهم الذين يعملون
رعايه بعثته الامم المتحده نعم هم رعاياهم
لكن يعملون في اللون المتحده يعني في جزء
منهم من المانيا من امريكا من ايضا بعض
الدول الاخرى الاوروبيه الان موجودين هنا
في
الميناء والان ينتظرونه لالتقاء برعاياهنا
الذين يعملون في الامم المتحده سوف نذهب
الى شق اخر ونتحدث عن الوضع الانساني الان
الذي يمر بها ويمر به السودان هل وصلتكم
اي بيانات او ايضا ارقام
يوضح الوضع الانساني هناك في ظل هذه
النزاعات بين طرفي النزاع
بالطبع الوضع الانساني متازم هنالك بشكل
عام فنعلم نحن الان الحصول على الرعايه
الصحيه فيه اشكالات هنالك كثير من
المستشفيات لا تعمل هنالك كثيره من الذين
يعني تاثر بهذه الظروف
بالقتال الان هنالك يعانون في الحصول على
الرعايه الصحيه او العلاج الاضافه لذلك
طبعا نعلم ان ايضا انه العلميه في خرطوم
بالذات غير موجوده في كل المناطق
الكهربائي ايضا لا في اشكاليه لكن
يحتاج لترتيب ليس لدينا ارقام محدد الان
لانه نحتاج ايضا
لامكانيه الحركه حتى
انا
لا تستطيعون التحرك الحركه محدوده مقصود
بظروف الامنيه الموجوده
حتى حتى لو المتحده لديها اشكالات في
التحرك ولكن بالتاكيد نحن ايضا نستطيع
التواصل مع طريف حي النزاع او في فتره
الهدنه وهنالك طبعا على مستوى قياده الامم
المتحده التواصل
الجهات المعنيه وذلك
لاحداث اختراق في وقف النار وحتى يساعد في
تقديم الدعم لكل المحتاجين يعني طيب وقفه
اطلاق النار مهم جدا وكذلك تامين مسارات
انسانيه لايصال
الدعم الانساني لكل المحتاجين في السودان
ان شاء الله شكرا لك سيد طيب اذا نعم
اذا شكرا لك السيد طيب اذا كان هذا حديث
السيد الطيب عن الوضع الانساني هناك وايضا
عن الرعايه الذين من جنسيه مختلفه والذين
الان سوف ينزلون من هذه الفرقاطه في ميناء
جده الاسلامي ايضا هاني اصفيان تابعنا
معصول هذه الفرقات الفرنسيه
لورين الى جده وعلى متنها 400 شخص
قادمين من السودان وربما ايضا الصوره قبل
قليل كانت
واضحه شكرا جزيلا لك ولضيفك الكريم هاني
اصفي المراسل العربيه من جده
اذا اثار تزايد جرائم السلب والنهب في
السودان غضب المواطنين خاصه مع غياب
الاجهزه العسكريه والامنيه وسط النزاع
الدائري في البلاد وين الشرطه
لسان حال المواطن السوداني خاصه في
العاصمه الخرطوم الاكثر اقتضاضا بالسكان
في السودان
التساؤلات عادت خاصه مع تزايد عمليات
السلب للمنازل والمحلات التجاريه ما اجبر
كثيرين على لزوم منازلهم
يتفتح
وجاري العسجد
تبييض المجوهرات ده برضو يتفتح نوضح نظافه
جديده السجون ايضا لم تسلم من حاله غياب
الامن عده سجون فتحت ابوابها والسجناء
كسروا قيودهم
تماما لا عنده اكل في ناس
مصادر في سجن كوبر من جانبها قالت ان فتح
السجن عائد لعدم توفر الامدادات الغذائيه
للسجناء وخوفا على سلامتهم وفي الشارع
الخالي يتساءل السودانيون رغم صدور اوامر
من الشرطه لعناصرها عند بدايه الازمه
بالحضور الى اقرب مركز امني
قال مصدران بمستشفى عسكري لرويترز ان
الرئيس السابق عمر البشير نقل من سجن كوبر
الى المستشفى قبل اندلاع القتال واصبح
مكانه تواجد البشير مثاره تساؤلات بعدما
اعلن الوزير السابق في حكومته علي هارون
امس الثلث انه غادر سجنه مع مسؤولين
السابقين اخرين وسط انباء عن نقل البشير
الى مكان امن غير معلوم
عقب الفرار والاضطرابات التي شهدتها
السجون السجون السود
اني قوات الدعم السريع بالوقوف وراء
العمليات وقال في بيان له ان السلطه اداره
السجون خارجا نطاق اختصاصه وتقع تحت
مسؤوليه وزاره الداخليه الجيش اشار الى
انه لا مصلحه له في خروج النزلاء من
سجونهم بهكذا طريقه والتي تضع امن الناس
وطمانينتهم على المحك مضيفا انه غير معنيا
باي بيانات تصدر من اي جماعه او افراد
خرجوا من السجون
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات